Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
Thank you for tuning in.
I'm going to start with a quote.
This one is from Steve Jobs.
Your time is limited,
so don't waste it living someone else's life.
Good advice.
The second thing I'm going to give you to start off is a probably useless way to
remember how large Mount Fuji is and that's 12,365 feet in terms of altitude and
the way you remember that is 12 months in a year,
365 days in a year.
So you're welcome.
This episode features Dan Carlin.
Dan Carlin is hugely impressive to me,
which is obvious when you listen to my initial ramblings and I am clearly
nervous and I stumble over a bunch of words,
uh,
which is hilarious.
So I hope you enjoy that awkwardness.
Dan has done many things in his life.
He's been on radio,
he has been on television,
but the way I came to know him was through hardcore history,
which is an incredible podcast and you should put aside for the moment any
reservations or doubts you have about a podcast based on history.
Of course,
this podcast Tim Ferriss show is about deconstructing excellence and if you
listen to one episode of hardcore history,
you will realize how absolutely stupendous and amazing Dan Carlin is.
So we,
we get into,
among other things,
his early beginnings stumbling in the beginning first versions of the podcast,
how he grew into it as a full time profession,
his influences,
his habits,
his rituals,
the things that he would do differently,
the things that he would tell himself when he was 20 years old and on and on and
on.
The point being to pull out tactics,
routines,
tools that you can use not only in podcasting but well outside of podcasting
makes people who are good in a particular arena tend to have a lot in common
with people who are the best in other arenas.
As always,
this podcast is supported by you guys,
so if you do like this podcast,
please visit four hour workweek.com forward slash books.
That is the home of the Tim Ferriss Book Club where I list a handful of books
that have had a huge impact on my life,
my career,
and I guarantee you will be extremely impressed and happy with them.
It's not too many and they'll link through to Amazon where you can take a look
at these various books and audio books.
So it's four hour workweek.com forward slash books.
Without further ado,
hope you enjoy the podcast and thanks for listening
at this altitude I can and start shaking from all else.
Are you posting a question?
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
Ladies and gentlemen,
and I have a treat for you.
We have Dan Carlin on the phone and Dan,
I have to tell you,
I have had uh,
some,
some fantastic folks on this podcast so far and I've met a lot of people in my
life and I have been so nervous about this particular conversation.
For weeks now and the part of the reason is there are very few podcasts that I
actually listened to on a regular basis and I'm hoping that by the end of this
conversation,
everyone who listens to this will at the very least listened to one full episode
of hardcore history and this is somewhat akin given that I'm a novice in the
podcasting arena.
To me getting in front of a crowd of tens or hundreds of thousands of people and
trying to say have a pass with a famous NFL quarterback or do a foul shot
competition with the top NBA player or something like that.
I've been so impressed by the quality of your podcasts and we've talked about
this before,
recognizing the amount of time and energy that you put into each one of these,
and we'll jump into things in a second,
but just as context I,
I had asked a number of my very close friends who are involved with audio
production and podcasts as well as video,
what their favorite podcasts where and almost without exception hardcore history
was listed in the top three for every single person.
And of course the first question I asked myself was,
how could a history podcast be one of the most popular podcasts out there?
And I remember downloading the very first episode that I heard of hardcore
history,
which was the prophets of doom.
And I looked at the length and I think it's well over four hours if I'm not
mistaken.
And I remember thinking to myself,
I'm going to download this.
I'm going to just get a taste for it for the first five to 10 minutes to see if
I can learn anything about the style.
And then that's going to be yet.
And I have digested now dozens and dozens and dozens of hours of your content.
So first and foremost,
thank you for putting so much effort into each of these episodes.
I don't always know how to react to such nice things that people say.
I mean,
uh,
it,
it's a fantastic compliment and I always tell people that I would love everyone
in their lives to get that feeling of that something you did was so well
received by people.
It's,
it's,
I feel very fortunate and a little like I stumbled into this and like you can't
even really take credit for it.
You just kind of fall into something that after you fall into it seems like
where you should have been all along.
So I feel like a really lucky guy to have stumbled into something that seems to
be so well received.
I appreciate that.
And uh,
yeah,
four hours.
I mean,
if you had told me when we started doing hardcore history that I was going to be
doing for our shows,
I think I would've canceled right then and there.
So you don't want to listen to it.
I didn't want it do.
So that's actually where I was hoping to start naturally at the beginning and
give people a little bit of background on how hardcore history came to be.
Because I remember you mentioned in a previous conversation that it started off
very,
very differently.
So I'm curious to know how it came to be and what your expectations were at the
time,
because certainly it's become an entity unto itself and it's turned into
something very,
very big.
But how did it,
how did it come together and how did it start off?
Well maybe other podcasters listening to you will be able to relate to this.
I've started a lot of shows in my life and a lot of them were radio shows and
whatnot and the one thing you learn when you start these shows is that all you
can do is come up with a concept and then try to take that concept where you
think it should go initially.
And then once you do that,
whatever you create is going to evolve.
And some of that evolution is in your control and some of it isn't in your
control.
I always say find your favorite TV series.
Take something like Seinfeld for example,
and then go look at the first five episodes and you'll notice that it's not
really Seinfeld yet.
They haven't figured,
it hasn't evolved into what really works and they haven't find,
but then eventually it finds its stride.
And so when you listen to our early episodes,
they don't sound a lot like what we're doing now either.
And I mean length is a perfect example.
There was a time where we were really scared of approaching an hour long program
and we used,
I remember one time,
it was,
I think it was with our Apache tears episode,
the ones we did on the Apaches and we were approaching an hour and then I got a
finished product and it was like one hour and 15 minutes and I said,
we're canceling the show.
We have to have to dial it back over an hour because no one will listen.
And so I think the fact that the audience had proven,
receptive gave us a feeling that there was some freedom here to go a little
farther and then a little farther.
And I'm shocked that everybody can listen to it that long.
Editing it for us.
We dread the hearing it over and over and over again.
So,
so I'm really not on the same wave length with a lot of the listeners.
Well speaking as someone who's written a 420 page book than a 592 page book and
then a 670 some odd pages.
Yeah,
same thing.
It really does take on a life of its own.
And I'm really glad you brought up the Seinfeld example because I remember
looking at say some of the,
the current versions of podcasts when I,
when I was considering doing my own,
looking at some of your newer episodes,
looking at some of the more polished Joe Rogan episodes,
which are also monsters looking at uh,
many different types.
And then someone recommended that I go back and look at say the first one or two
episodes that Joe did on video and they're hilariously amateur.
I mean really,
really hilarious.
And if I hadn't done that,
I think I would have been too intimidated to get started because I would have
falsely assumed that the polished format that you've arrived at where you
started and that that reflects an intrinsic ability that I entirely lack,
which could also still be true.
But what I'd,
I'd love to know is with hardcore history in particular,
and we'll talk about the podcast.
I also want to talk about history,
but were there any particular tipping points that that helped you start to form
it into what it is now?
And I'm sure it's still evolving,
but were,
were there any particular tipping points,
whether it was in popularity,
specific episodes,
Aha moments that come to mind for you?
Content or format wise?
I think we had ideas when we started it,
a things we wanted to do and then a couple shows into it.
You could start to sense that these were elements that you should have in every
single episode.
So for example,
uh,
somewhere along the line I'd always had these,
these sort of twilight zone kind of ideas about history.
And when we could start to say,
okay,
every episode really is successful if it has some of those,
some of the drama,
some of the narratives.
So you start to,
to figure out what the ingredients in your creation are.
And once that's the case,
then you can start to say,
it's not so much a formula as a checklist and say,
okay,
every good episode that we do should have a,
B,
c,
d,
and e and I'm not sure when you start that you're totally aware of that.
You're still playing around with the ingredients and the mix.
And,
and we still do that.
I mean,
each episode's going to sound different because we want to put extra cumin in
this one and less hot sauce in that one.
But,
but at the same time you don't really know what's working in the first few
episodes.
And so somewhere,
somewhere around like,
um,
we did one called step stories early on,
which is sort of a loose look at all the different people in the culture and
history of the,
of the giant flat area,
you know,
that starts in eastern Europe and goes almost all the way to the Pacific Ocean.
And we did a show like that and it was the first time I think we hit the sweet
spot with all of those elements in it.
And when you heard it,
you just said,
okay,
that that's significantly better than anything else we've done.
And that's what you sit there and go,
okay,
well w w we figured out how to do this kind of and we're going to start to not
mass produce it,
but we're gonna make sure that we do a better job in every later episode.
That incorporates all these things that we think started have started to blend
well.
I am currently listening,
or I should say relistening to the wrath of the cons,
which is a a audio book or three worth of content in and of itself.
And it seems like having pulled my being a 500,000 or so people on Twitter,
that that is one of the most popular series,
so to speak.
And I'm,
I'm curious to know if there are any episodes that you thought were going to be
a huge hit that we're not or if there are any episodes that were completely
added,
left field.
A huge,
a huge home run.
Well,
it's nice to hear you say that because I think I left a little bit of my sanity
with that wrath of the con series,
and the truth is,
is that the longer multipart series where we take on some big issue and it takes
four or six episodes hours long each,
and you have an audio book at the end to do,
are so challenging because you have all these loose threads that developed while
you're doing the story,
and then by the time you hit the middle of the series,
you have to start tying those threads together and it becomes,
you know,
I'm in one of these things now we're talking about the first world war and we're
in episode four and all of a sudden the whole thing is unraveling in front of my
face and it does it.
Does Tat Challenge your sanity a bit?
I'm always surprised when the shows are well received,
so I don't have anywhere I was going,
oh,
this is going to be a home run.
I'm always sure I screwed up one way or the other.
So it's never,
never happens that I'm sure it's a hit.
Oftentimes I released something and I just braced myself for what I'm sure is
going to be this negative response,
prophets of doom,
uh,
that you like.
I didn't think at the end where I said I earned it.
Yeah.
It was like a disclaimer saying this didn't come out the way I want it.
And people liked it anyway.
So that's usually what happens.
I'm a little bit more of a perfectionist.
I,
I was reading a book the other day on the rolling stones and they have this
picture in it of their guitarist,
Keith Richards just hanging over this audio board and you can see he's been up
for like days and they're,
and they're unlike the hundredth taken.
This song in this album is overdue and the whole time,
and I thought to myself,
it's not all that different than what we're doing here.
And so,
so I'm always sure that this next show we're going to release is going to
destroy our brand forever and that I'm never going to live up to the hype and
that,
uh,
I'm,
the sanity is,
has been left in the studio somewhere.
Profit to doom is a perfect example.
The Apache tears show where we,
I think it was the first one either we were near over an hour.
I was sure people were going to freak out about that.
So pretty much every episode I release,
I'm sure that's the end we screwed up.
And you mentioned the aspect of tying loose ends together,
and this is something I feel very familiar with,
just having put together books with multiple storylines and dozens of different
components.
However,
with the printed word,
I have the luxury of being able to go back,
copy and paste,
cut out sections,
translate them to other areas.
But with audio,
after you've recorded say two,
three episodes,
you really have to work with,
I would imagine on some level what you've already done.
So I'd love to hear how on earth you prepare for these things,
what the process currently looks like.
Because when I listened to the prophets of doom and at the end,
like you said,
the disclaimer came out where you say that it didn't really turn out the way you
expected it to or wanted to two and that you'd,
you'd actually recorded,
and I have to just hear it from the horses mouth here are recorded a complete
version of that episode that you then scrapped.
I just couldn't fathom taking the time to record that and then scrap it and
start over.
I mean it just blew my mind.
So could you talk a little bit about the process?
How do you research,
how do you choose topics when you're going after an episode like this?
Because it sounds very masterfully delivered.
So one of the,
the thoughts that occurred to me for instance,
was how often do you stop?
Like how long does it take,
in other words,
and so on and so forth.
So that I'd love for you to just discuss if you would be open to,
it's kind of start to finish what the process looks like for putting one of
these shows together.
Well,
let me back up because you had talked about doing a book and,
and,
and there are,
there are similarities when you do these really long podcast and especially in
these series,
we have a name for it in house,
I call it the blue room and,
and the,
and the Blue Room is when you've heard the piece so often,
and this happens with reading too,
so I'm sure you have the same problem with books where you were,
you've now seen it so often that you lose the ability to absorb it the way a new
listener would or a new reader would definitely.
And it destroys your ability to judge what you have.
So I mean it's the only time I get jealous of like the TV networks and stuff
where they're able to bring in test audiences and show them something that they
put together and just say,
okay,
so what's your reaction to this?
Because they have the same problem we do.
Right?
They get the blue room,
but they have the chance to expose a few people to it and say,
okay,
is this good when we've lost all sense of direction on this?
Now the bad part of that is then you can then the audience can start driving it.
You don't want that either from a creative sense,
but when we hit where we are in this show now,
I haven't the slightest idea if that even make sense anymore or like you'll hear
something and you'll go,
this sounds remarkably similar to something I think I said seven hours ago in
art too.
And so you,
you,
and like you said,
at least it's easier to do that in the written sense,
but the same problem exists.
So when you say,
how do you do these things?
The reason it gets complicated where we are now is that I have to write some of
that stuff down and say,
no,
you talked about this already.
Don't talk about this again.
As opposed to saying what I'm going to do.
And it's part of keeping the,
you know,
don't cross the streams.
Like they said in Ghostbusters.
It's trying not to cross tangents and streams and,
and,
and the only part that's a saving grace in the episode we're doing now is in the
first world war,
things are repetitive and it's actually a part of the story.
That's how people at the time felt like,
oh my God,
we're still going through the same,
it's the same movie over and over again.
So if I make the listeners feel that way in the show,
I can,
if the cop out is going to be able to say,
and I'm going to say it well now you feel just like the people in the story.
So if I sound repetitive,
we were after that.
Um,
so,
so if you ask how I do it,
I really do.
I pick subjects that I already know about and then I begin the research from
there.
Cause I always tell people,
someone will say,
can you please talk about the history of southeast India or something?
And I'll say,
you don't want me to talk.
I don't know anything about that.
And you can't educate yourself to a reasonable standard in the short period of
time we have.
I have,
it's enough for me to pick a subject I know lot about.
I know a lot about the first world war and I've read 50 books since we started
this.
They grew on top of that.
What's amazing to me is how much has changed since I thought I learned about
these things.
Maybe,
maybe the 1980s I,
I was really into that subject for a few years and you go back and you think,
well there can't be that much more about this 100 year old subject since then,
you couldn't be more wrong.
Right.
There's books and revisions and new points of view and it,
it's,
it's insane.
So I picked these topics I already have a good foundation for and I've thrown
away by the way you're talking about throwing away shows.
I threw away a show on the Greeks and the ancient Persians.
I think I threw away one of the Apache shows.
So I've done this before,
but I pick a,
something I know a bunch about and I,
I think about it.
And this is the thing that listeners never give me any time for because
basically I'm behind schedule what I start and the listeners are always
wondering what I'm doing.
But you actually have to sit down a little bit and think and just,
and just sit in the shower and just go,
what's weird about this story and what turns me,
you know?
And that's where you come up with these weird sort of things.
And those things are,
the pillar is we sort of build the showrunner.
We say it's a little like our style is a jazz like or led Zepplin used to have
a,
a line for how they constructed their work.
They said,
they said our format is tight but loose and that,
and that's kind of how artists is.
Where,
where there are these mileposts that I set that I want to get to.
But within those mile posts I have all this room to sort of go off on a,
yeah.
Guitar Solo for a long period of time or like tangents.
If you can't stand tangents,
you can't listen to my stuff.
Cause that's,
I mean it's like the tangents or maybe the pillar of the show.
We just go off on all these avenues.
You couldn't structure it if you tried to write it out that way wouldn't work.
But I think it does come across perhaps as disjointed sometimes.
Or maybe this solo has gone on too long and we need to get back to the format or
whatever.
But I do,
I go into the studio with kind of a concept and an approach.
I want to try to,
to make work and it doesn't always work out.
And I'll go in there and usually I'm,
you know,
coffee used to work so much better for me in the old days,
but,
but I'll have a bunch of cups of coffee.
I'll get in there and I'll just start talking about it.
And usually it's pretty good for a while and then it breaks down at some point
and that's where I'll stop and then I'll,
I'll pick up from just before it broke down the session before and we'll try to
string something together now.
Sometimes I'll go and listen.
I'll go,
oh wow,
we really left this part out.
Or Oh that's a,
there's a mistake in there we have to fix.
And so there's going back and pulling the rolling stones and the in the studio
obsessing over,
take 99 of,
you know,
uh,
one of their songs.
And we do some of that now too.
And we do a lot more than we used to because when you're doing four and five
hour episodes,
you can't keep it straight.
So we're constantly relistening to the stuff and it's become a lot more
structured than it used to be.
I used to be able to walk in there and say,
if we get lucky,
I'll walk out in the studio with a whole hardcore history show for you.
That doesn't happen anymore.
Um,
so,
so you go to run out of gas,
I guess is what I'm saying.
And when you're planning,
let's just say a single episode,
not a series,
but a single episode that could be two to four hours in length.
How much of what I hear as a listener is scripted out is written out in long
form.
What are your prompts?
Look like or your props so to speak,
because I'm thinking about how I prepare for say a keynote presentation,
a 60 minute keynote presentation.
There are cases where I'll have portions that are verbatim that I'll memorize a
just for delivery sake,
say at the beginning and the very end.
Then there are in some cases bullet points that I use to break say a section
into three parts so that it's easier to rehearse as well as as nail repeatedly,
but I've been mystified trying to figure out because I'm just purely guessing
what you have in front of you when you're recording and sort of generally
speaking,
how often you take breaks,
for instance,
say 10 minutes,
20 minutes,
30 minutes.
What does that look like these days when you're doing a single episode as
opposed to a series?
Well,
I hope you can tell that there is no script because there is,
there is no script and that and we hope that that's why it sounds natural like
it does.
Well,
the only reason that I ask is because it's so,
it sounds so polished without the ums and Ahs and I'm accustomed to hearing for
almost everyone that I've ever heard in long form conversation that it just
seemed like a super power to not have a script,
I guess.
So
that's understand that there's definitely editing going on there.
I mean,
I'm sure that we've taken out some ums and things like that before,
but I mean,
you know,
I did radio for a dozen years before I did podcasts and I did television before
then.
And ums are a pretty basic thing.
You work on it.
It doesn't mean we're Umphrey,
it just means that I'm less likely to pull an um,
and then I might have been,
and I always said,
you know,
we kind of had an advantage when we got into podcasting.
Well,
first of all,
we got in so early,
it was a little like the Oklahoma Land Rush.
So it was right.
It was nice to get in there so early and sort of claim your little zone.
But also I wasn't learning how to do proper mic technique.
You know what,
I was starting at a little bit of an advantage.
And so with the oms fall into that category a little bit in terms of,
um,
I mean we do write down,
for example,
if I've got a twisty idea that I want to make sure to include,
I might write down the twisty idea and then post that up on the cork board to
remind myself that in this 20 minute segment today you want to hit that idea.
I also find,
you know,
what you call primary source account.
So somebody is in the first world war war and there's,
they talk about what it's like in the trenches and I'll know that I have that
piece.
And so I'll have a note that says,
okay,
page two 46 of this book.
You know,
and I'll have mark that guy as quote.
And so I'll know I have that,
but I don't know exactly when I'm going to get to it.
I just know that some were in today's session,
you're probably gonna run into the point where it's logical to put that primary
source quote in so that that's how I organize it.
Otherwise it's,
it's a free form sort of improvisational talk.
God,
it's amazing.
I want to give people a couple of different options for places to start with
hardcore history because it really,
I'm seldom as impressed as I have been with the entire show,
but stop it dude.
You're,
I know,
I know.
I'm making things awkward.
Everybody was not of good people out there.
There are a lot of good people out there,
but I've sort of gotten stuck on hardcore history.
So I feel like I need to satisfy that fixed first.
But one thing I think that you do very,
very well,
and I,
I'd like to ask you how much of this was learned over time.
And also I'll get to the second part,
but you do a very good job of pulling listeners into the episodes.
And the example that jumps to mind is you might have a description,
say in the case of wrath of the cons of some of the historical context,
some of the,
the various cultures and step communities in different areas.
And then you'll say,
you know,
imagine if you will,
that you have an entire army comprised of circus trick archers.
And then not only do they have Bose with the bows are 130 pound poll,
which happens to mean more to me these days because I've been playing around
with archery and I know how hard it is,
at least for me to repeatedly pull,
say a 55 or 60 pound.
So the fact that they get unleashed,
you know,
60 hours a minute or whatever it was,
but you pull people in with the,
you know,
imagine if you were,
and then doing hypothetical's with of course the Martians and so on,
the verbal delivery that you have,
which is very polished.
And of course you've done a lot of radio and a lot of television,
but if someone feels self conscious about their own vocal delivery and they want
to podcast,
maybe I'm projecting here,
but how would you suggest that people work on that skill and try to refine their
delivery to get a little closer to what I would consider very,
very professional in your case?
Well,
I appreciate you saying that because I came up in radio at a time,
the tail end of what maybe you could call the big voice era where radio was
still,
this won't mean anything to all of the young listeners,
but like a Gary Owens deep classical,
almost a stereotypical old fashioned broadcast.
Your style with the deep pipes or the way the guys used to describe their voices
and when I came up,
I remember the boss at the radio station where I worked,
I mean at one time he actually suggested I have like adenoid surgery or
something.
Maybe get that deep voice that that was the classic that they were looking for
and I not only didn't have that,
I didn't want that.
I just wanted to talk the way I talk.
And then somewhere while I was doing that,
that whole deep voice thing went out of fashion and everybody was more looking
for a unique,
you were looking for your own voice,
right?
A unique voice that sounded like no one else.
And luckily just having your own voice,
as long as it didn't great like nails on a blackboard,
which some people said mine did.
So it's,
it's an acquired taste maybe.
But having your own voice became the real preferred format and all of a sudden
everybody is saying,
gosh,
it's so great you have your own voice.
And all I'm thinking about is all those years that that was the one thing
everybody didn't want me to have.
So when you say to a listener,
how do you get more polished and broadcasts or like there's a process you're
going to go through if you start podcasting or whatever,
where you figure out what your voice is and it shouldn't be something fake.
It should be your voice.
But maybe you take it down a range maybe because we've all got a vocal range
right from the highest.
You speak to the lowest you speak.
There may be a sweet spot in there and it might not be the way you always talk
are you or you might want to talk in that in that tone more.
I think personally that there is no perfect voice and I think that that as long
as as you like it and you sound the way you want to sound that that's,
especially in this world,
I mean what I love about the podcast and the the Internet is that there's so
many potential people out there listening that if you just be yourself,
you're going to attract listeners who like that and then you never have to fool
around with trying to be someone else to please your audience because the people
that you've attracted are there because they like you are ready.
Right?
I don't think you should try to develop some style other than just Polish your
own style.
The oms are a perfect example,
but listen,
I bet if you wanted to,
you could weave that into your style where that's almost your thing,
right?
I mean,
we talk around here a lot about turning negatives into positives or lemons into
lemonade or creatively taking a weak spot and making it a strong spot.
I always was heavily in the red as they say,
when I was on the radio where I yelled so loud and I still do that.
The meter just jumps up into the red and they would say,
you need,
you need to speak in this one zone of of loudness or you'll screw up the,
the radio stations compression.
Well,
after a while I just started writing liners for the big voice guidance.
You know,
here's Dan Carlin.
He talks so loud or whatever.
I said,
this is who am I?
That's my style.
I meant to do that.
And it's a matter of fact.
I,
if you do it,
you're imitating me.
So,
so it's the hardly partly taking what you already do and saying,
no,
this isn't a negative.
This is the thing I bring to the table buddy.
Right?
You know,
I copyrighted that.
I talk real loud and then I talked really quietly.
And if you have a problem with that,
well you don't understand what a good style is.
Tim.
I like that.
I will.
I think I shall capitalize on this hobby,
right?
Your faults,
you reminded me of actually an experience that I had with writing the four hour
workweek.
What was my first book?
I
was very nervous about it and when I first started,
and I'm not sure how many people know this,
I wrote the first four or five chapters and ended throwing them all out because
I was writing in this very pompous sort of Ivy League style that I thought
sounded very smart and it came off stilted and it just,
it,
it was very unattractive.
So I tossed it and then I tried to write an amusing fashion.
I thought I needed to be funny.
So I was like,
all right,
I'll,
I'll be funny.
I should stop being so serious.
And it came across very slapstick.
Three stooges.
So yet again,
I had to take these four or five chapters that I'd spent weeks on and throw them
out and ultimately found my own voice,
which was really just discovering something that was latent and that people felt
in conversation by having two glasses of wine and,
and starting to write as if it were an email to two specific friends.
And that is when I finally found the proper balance,
which was intrinsically how I spoke to my close friends about serious subjects.
Uh,
after a couple of glasses,
one was there a point and also brings to mind a,
there's a,
a friend of mine named Gary Vaynerchuk who became well known after doing
something called Wine Library TV.
And if you look at the very first say 10 episodes,
especially the first few,
he's really subdued and you learn later,
of course he,
he sort of grown into himself and he has a very bombastic style,
but that's who Gary is.
But it took them a long time to get there.
And were there any sort of,
uh,
points for you aside from embracing this,
this extremely flexible vocal range that you talked about where you kind of got
comfortable in your own shoes and we're able to not no longer conform to other
expectations people had of what a good say radio host was or podcaster?
Well,
if you go listen to even my earlier podcast,
the one thing you're going to notice is I talked faster,
I was louder,
I was more aggressive and all,
and people go and listen to it now and go,
God,
when did you slow down?
Or I'm glad you slowed down or something like that.
And I always say,
but it wasn't,
it wasn't intentional.
I just got older and the coffee doesn't work as well.
And yet,
and yet it slowed me down to a level that more people are comfortable with and
the way I used to be.
But it wasn't intentional.
I mean,
I would've been perfectly happy attracting whatever audience liked that style
more.
But I think there's a natural aging,
and I mean,
I think you hear it with singers or anyone else where the style doesn't change
because the singer doesn't like singing the way that they used to sing.
They just,
their voices different and their energy is different.
And Luckily for me,
me getting older and slower and,
and Mellower is easier on more listeners I guess,
than the style I had when I was younger.
And I'll tell you what I missed as I get older,
you know,
I've gotten to the age now where where sometimes I'll reach for some fact or
something that's in my memory banks and it longer to get than it used to.
In the old days,
I was so fast and it wasn't just vocally,
it was,
it was indicative of how fast my brain was working in my mouth,
was trying to keep up with my brain and now my brain has slowed down.
And so I feel like an athlete who's past their prime,
right?
Who's who say I used to be able to run a four,
three 40 man and now I can't do it anymore.
But the people like it slower.
So in a funny way,
I've aged to a point where more people are comfortable listening to my
middle-age style than they weren't listening to me when,
when they used to call me the angry young wolf back on,
if you can believe that.
Yeah.
So it could be worse,
could be worse.
That was one of the better nicknames until he gets a lot worse.
A lot worse than that.
So who are some of your favorite podcasters or radio personalities or people on
audio?
I guess what I'd love to know are people who have inspired you or people you
admire in the audio medium as it were.
They could be living dead current,
up and coming really doesn't matter.
But I'd be curious to know who you have looked up to or admire in that world.
Well,
I appreciate you saying living dead long because here's the dirty little secret
of my life and it's very hard to explain to people.
I do not consume much media anymore.
That is not text based.
So people will say,
have you seen this show or have you seen this movie?
Or have you listened to this podcast?
And I can almost say with 100% certainty,
no,
and it's going to get me into trouble.
I tell other people I'm going to rip off some well known movie or TV show theme
or something someday without knowing that I've ripped it off.
You know,
I almost did once I did this thing once where I,
I had this break comparison for this one episode we did and somebody who
listened to it before I released it,
thank goodness,
had to tell me that.
I was just giving the listeners the plot of Avatar,
which was,
which was the big movie out then that I hadn't seen and I thought that's a great
way to stumble into a copyright infringement or look like you're ripping
somebody off.
So I haven't really consumed media in a long time and it's not on purpose.
I just,
I'm not in a place in my life where I have that kind of time right now.
But of course we were all influenced by people I had 'em in the same way you
were talking about how much you're,
you're,
you know,
you like interviewing me while I like interviewing people and I like to
interview James Burke and we did it in a show,
the guy who was the famous host of the connections series,
the day the universe changed in an Irish guy and as someone with a Irish genes
myself had I admired Burke from a long time ago and the way has wonderful mind
thought and the way he would,
he would string ideas together.
And so for me,
it'll Gwynne Dyer.
We had Gwynne Dyer on the program with a Canadian journalist who did a wonderful
series when I was growing up on war.
That got me where I live somewhere deeply.
You know,
I,
I was an old,
um,
when I was a TV reporter,
I was on a CBS affiliate and at CBS,
the,
the soul of Edward r Murrow sort of runs deep.
And so those of us who were serious reporting,
which was not all of us,
took a real,
I mean that that was a really important thing for people,
especially of a tradition history minded kind of thing to look up to and to
shoot for.
I mean you know sometimes you aspire to be things that you know you can never
quite achieve,
but the attempt to reach those heights even if you fall short is a good goal to
set.
And so those are the kinds of people that I look up to.
And I think a lot of times when we're doing,
especially the hardcore history podcast,
you look at people like Orson wells and people who were involved in audio when
audio was the main medium and say that those people did a lot of things that we
could recreate.
Again,
when you talk about like a theater of the mind approach,
the little known fact we used to do theater of the mind stuff on the older
history shows and if you listen really carefully with,
it's crazy cause we put this immense amount of effort.
It's hard to even describe how much effort basically composing an audio score
for these episodes.
But we wanted to make it optional so that you didn't have to hear the score if
you didn't want to.
So we made,
so we,
cause we didn't know if it was a plus or a minus,
and we thought it might be a plus to the people who liked it,
but a minus to the people who didn't.
So we made it so quiet that you literally have to,
I have to sit in a room and put your headphones on and crank it up and get into
it.
We have candles on or whatever the listeners do and then you can enjoy it.
But if you're in your car or on the bus or what,
you won't hear it.
And people love that.
It was all theater of the mind.
And I,
I,
that's the way I loved it too.
I mean,
if I could do it anyway,
again,
I would throw the theater and the optional theater of the mind stuff back in it.
But it was like doing an episode after you'd already finished an episode.
I mean we'd have to do the show and then score the show and it just at a certain
point in order to free up,
I mean we already weren't getting shows out fast enough.
We had to drop that.
But if I could ever do it the way I want to,
again I would go back to scoring the shows with sound effects and little hums
and drones and because we've got a whole,
I mean you can go back and listen.
A bunch of our shows have all these,
it's not quite put on the wizard of Oz at the same time.
We start the podcast and you'll follow along.
But there's,
we do a lot of fun stuff that I miss.
I mean in bubonic nukes,
the one we did on the black plague,
my favorite part of that whole episode is at the very end.
We're talking about how you may think that this is a long time ago,
but you know,
it might not be as long as you think.
And then we have the sound really quiet in the background of a laboratory beaker
dropping.
And then you hear a here,
a red alert alarm going off like,
like you just,
the CDC lost a flu virus or something.
And so I used to love the potential of throwing in the Orson Welles theater of
the mind type stuff.
And so when I look back on,
on the greats of the past,
at this point,
I'm almost looking back on them the way led Zeppelin looked at blues men that
they could rip off.
I'm going to try to find little techniques they can steal that they used to do.
But,
but yeah,
so I mean,
I wouldn't say that there are specific individuals as much as,
oh my gosh,
that's a great show or that's a great idea.
So I'm not listening to a great song.
I'm listening to a great riff and going,
Oh,
I love that little drum beat right in there.
I could rip that off.
Or you know,
so,
so right now that,
that's more influential to me than any particular broadcast.
But yeah,
I,
I loved so much growing up.
Obviously
you mentioned text.
I am a really avid reader.
I love books,
always have,
and it's clear that you do a ton of research for these shows.
A couple of questions related to books.
What is the book that you've given most as a gift to other people?
Oh my goodness.
Or books,
you know,
I have to tell you the truth.
I don't do that either.
And people say to me all the time,
can you recommend a book for a,
B or c?
And I rarely do because I'm not reading general stuff.
A lot of times I'm reading really weird sort of books that would like,
like you get into this world war one subject that I meant to you now.
So then you're finding these weird little things that aren't gonna mean anything
to someone unless they've read some of the other books that I read before that.
So my stuff is not really useful to people.
I'm trying to think what,
if anything I gave to and I've really horrible gift giver to Tim.
Thanks for exposing all of my weaknesses here publicly.
That's what,
that's why my wife is so fantastic.
A gift giving.
She makes up for me.
Um,
I'm going to have to pass on that.
Okay.
No problem.
The answer.
All right.
No problem.
Gift Giver.
That's my answer.
I would give,
give her,
are there any,
all right,
let's take a different tech.
Do you have any favorite documentaries or movies?
I know you don't consume a lot of media these days,
but what I'm trying to figure out is what,
and maybe this is a separate question,
but what made you so fascinated in history,
and I know you've studied it before,
but for a lot of people they take the,
the viewpoint that,
well,
histories in the past,
I don't feel like getting into esoteric aspects of,
of old civilizations when I should be focusing on ABC theory.
Of course,
there's a lot of practicality I think in,
in,
uh,
in studying quite a bit of history,
which tends to repeat itself.
But I'm trying to identify for someone who is not,
aside from listening to the podcast of course,
which I think is the easiest answer to get someone hooked on history,
even indirectly.
Are there any documentaries,
movies,
books,
anything that come to mind?
That's a bunch of different questions that was loaded.
Let me take them one at a time.
Um,
some of the movies that I enjoy watching,
it's so perverse and to bring them up because they're,
they're not good movies.
A lot of times,
like for example,
I tell my wife,
if it has time travel in it,
I'm likely to watch it.
Whether or not I have any interest in,
I mean that's what gets me forget about,
oh,
this is a great film.
I have to,
I'll give you a perfect example.
There was a movie,
I think they did it in late 1970s or maybe 1980 I think it came out called the
final countdown.
And it's relatively horrible as the movie goes,
but it doesn't matter.
The story is about what if a modern aircraft carrier went back to the eve of the
Pearl Harbor attack and,
and so it's taking on Japanese zeroes with modern airplanes and forget it.
The story can suck.
No,
I man,
right.
That's all I need.
The acting can be Tara.
I don't care.
See,
so,
so that's a perfect example of a movie that we grabbed me just,
okay,
conceptually I'm all in.
You don't even have to execute it and lizard with our podcast.
I mean,
we kind of go there sometimes too.
Hopefully these twists or enough to disguise the fact maybe we didn't tie this
other thought together so well or,
or,
or I go off on too many tangents.
The other point about you're,
I think you're striving to try to find how the history bug got started in me and
I think we've been trying to figure that out in my family forever.
My Mother's concept is that I was somehow born with it because I was into it.
It's such a,
you know,
I mean you,
you could give me history related things at Christmas when I'm four and I'm into
it and there's no explanation.
I just think you have to suggest that a lot of us are hardwired to like this or
that.
And in my case,
you know,
I mean some people you give a musical instrument too,
and Oh my God,
they're four years old and they're playing like a teenager.
For me it was,
it was stuff from the past and,
and I don't know,
but I've been into it since I was very little,
which is,
it's so,
it's so weird to me to be able to make a living doing something.
That's what I mean.
When I,
when we started this conversation,
I said,
you know,
I've really been fortunate to fall into something that you almost seem to have
been born to do.
And I don't know how I got so lucky,
but everybody should have this feeling,
you know,
to feel like,
God,
I eye catching a football.
It's just,
I've been doing it since I was two.
It's the thing I do best in life and somebody gave me a job catching a football.
So I mean,
that's how I feel that,
that there's a little bit,
you know,
when you talk about being born to something,
I guess what I do is storytelling because that's what people tell me.
I do.
I think there's a storytelling gene and you know,
and I think,
I think it runs in families.
I think the Irish people in my family could tell a hell of a story long before I
was on this planet.
And if you're lucky,
you get some of that.
And so I think there's a bunch of those elements that just work in,
in our favor and we're,
and we're taking our strengths and running with them.
And so when you talk about how you put a podcast together,
one of the things I would suggest that people do is build it around what you do
well,
you know,
and,
and so,
and so I feel like I'm just utilizing whatever talents I was born with and it's
working out.
I mean that I can do this instead of working on the assembly line is one of the
great gifts in my life.
You know,
it seems,
and please correct me if I'm wrong,
that that hardcore history at least has existed since 2006 is that right?
You might know better than I do something along those.
Someone.
I think the other podcast is 2005 and hardcore history come sometime after that.
Right.
So this,
like you said,
you've,
you've been in
this game,
we're in this medium for some time.
When did it occur to you that you might be able to do this full time?
When did that transition take place and when?
Was there a particular moment that stands out to you when you realized that
people have been telling me for a long time that we could do this?
Long before I thought we could do this,
I had a guy hire me,
a tech guy,
hire me back in 96 off the radio to do our show on the Internet.
And I look at him like he was crazy because I didn't because,
well one the Internet wasn't,
that wasn't that
there wasn't,
the mechanisms didn't exist.
And he said,
well,
that's what my company,
we'll do.
We'll invent the mechanisms to do this.
And you'll be like the test case,
right?
You'll show people,
uh,
it never went anywhere.
But ever since then the discussion of how do we put Dan on the Internet has been
going on amongst people that I just had to trust knew better than I did about
that.
Um,
and the implication always was that you would have more listeners,
cause I was always,
I always say I was,
I was the,
the messed up part of the radio stations Dave part whenever I was on because I
just was a Martian,
I never fit.
I mean I'm apparently it was good enough to stay employed,
but I never fit with the programming.
And so,
so the attitude was that's what the Internet's for.
You'll be able to reach this mass of people that are above and beyond your
normal talk radio show demographic.
And that turned out to be true.
But the implication was that if you had a bunch of listeners,
you'd be an idiot not to be able to figure out one way or another how to get,
how to make money off of that.
For me,
what saved me was the listeners.
They treated,
I mean I went to a bunch of people before we started asking for donations.
We had done the show for years before we asked for any donations or any money or
anything.
And I went to a bunch of experts I trust in business and law and a bunch of
other areas and I solicited their advice and said,
if we ask the listeners to donate to this,
will that work?
And every single one of them said,
not a chance in hell.
Really,
really intelligent,
smart people.
And I,
and I was dissuaded and I thought,
oh my goodness,
all these people are.
And we thought,
well,
let's just do it anyway.
What are you going to lose?
We're just asking the listeners if,
if you,
if you think what you heard was worth a dollar,
give us the dollar.
Save up so you have five and then give us five,
whatever.
And Oh my gosh,
that's changed our lives.
And so when I talk about how fortunate I feel to be doing this,
let's not forget who I owe for this.
A bunch of people who didn't have to pay,
we give them away for free.
They didn't have to do this.
I mean,
it's like what Radiohead did when they put that song out on the Internet instead
of instead of putting it on the radio or selling it as a CD and saying,
just give us what you think it's worth.
And it worked out better.
Now I don't know if this is sustainable,
right?
I don't know if this is a flash in the pan or whatever,
but at the moment what people have done is make possible professional and mature
media.
I know that sounds like a contradiction in terms,
but that's what we and and so I owe a lot of people out there listening to your
show in mine and lots of other podcasts for giving me this blessing that I do
and I mean I talk about it too much.
I'm sure it gets old,
but I wake up in the middle of the night and just say thank you.
You know,
it's crazy to me.
I'm going to tone down my over the top praise.
But I mean it's,
it's very clear that you put a lot of effort,
a ton of effort in prep into the episodes,
which I think is part of the reason why people are so willing to donate.
For instance,
what has been the most popular episode to date?
If you had to guess or popular episodes
they say in history,
like if you're,
the history channel for example,
that the subject that people get the most excited about is the second world war
and that's why I think they did it to death on the history channel and stuff
like that because it's almost something you have to screw up to not do well
with.
The only real time that we've touched that subject dead on is when we talked
about in a multipart series,
the eastern front in the Second World War,
so basically the war between the Germans and the Soviet Union.
Although there are a lot of other people involved,
most Americans,
and I didn't realize this actually don't know much about that because they hear
so much about the stuff that our side was involved with that to them as a part
of the war that that essentially gave us the advantage of stuff.
Taking that subject.
That's gold,
right?
Second World War.
It's history gold and yet a part of it that people weren't aware of.
So it's like finding new world war two stuff.
I mean it's give you the history channel and go guess what all this World War
Two stuff you haven't explored yet.
I mean all my,
it's like finding gold and so we,
we told this story and people love it.
This is the ghost of the oss friends.
So of the oss from,
yeah,
lost friend is the German word for eastern front.
You know,
if you took,
and we,
I think we said this in the show,
I can't remember what we said yesterday much this what we said that,
but if you take just the eastern front of the Second World War and isolate that
as its own war,
it by itself is the biggest war in human history all by itself.
And so I think the stories that come out of that and the horrific newness and
the feeling of the people who must have been trapped in that dynamic are such
that people listen to it and I think can really relate.
And,
and again,
having,
having a new World War II subject,
especially one that's so big,
I mean,
when you hear that,
you really understand that the war was probably won or lost on the eastern
front.
And so I think it had all the elements right there to be a really popular
episode.
If I don't screw it up right,
uh,
it doesn't seem like you did the w what,
what episode did you have?
I know how stressful it must be.
It is.
I want to,
people don't understand it.
It's become a lot more stressful than it used to be.
All good stuff.
I'm glad to be doing it,
but,
but we're stressed right now,
for example.
So what,
Eh,
whether it's with stress or without which,
which episode are episodes,
did you have the most fun personally recording?
Whether it's researching,
we're recording.
Oh,
I could cheat on
this answer though,
because we did a three interview shows before the audience informed me that they
get hugely let down when they finally see a hardcore history show,
you know,
after waiting forever for a new one.
And instead of being what they expect,
they get an interview show.
But I like the interviews are fun because you can do them in real time.
I mean,
you basically take an hour to talk to someone you admire for an hour and then
you have a show,
oh my gosh,
I want three months now working on the latest hardcore history show.
So I love that.
And I get to talk to two people that I admire,
like James Burke.
But in terms of the other shows,
I won't lie to you.
And none of them were easy.
And they get harder and,
and I don't know why I keep doing that to myself.
I'm,
my wife was saying,
why don't you just pick a nice small,
easy topic and do that?
And I don't know why.
Because there's something about feeling like I'm pushing myself.
I mean,
if I have some creative brain cells,
I am using every single one of them.
I will not be able to say as I'm laying on my death bed somewhere that I didn't
push myself to the limit.
And on these shows,
we'll go from that Mongol series,
which like I said,
I think I left some of my sanity in the studio and decided to do the first world
war after that.
What's sort of Masochists does that cam?
Um,
I think,
yeah,
I think we're cut from the same cloth
who she was doing the thinking in this company.
Right.
But,
but,
but so the answer is it's just when I think I'm going to have some fun with one
of these things,
I decided to take on something that,
listen,
there's no question.
By the time it's done,
it's very satisfying to say,
hey,
people like that.
We get a lot of good,
hard work and it paid off.
But while you're in the midst of it,
and first of all,
I'm not sure it isn't going to crumble like an airplane crash,
you know,
I don't know that,
that we're going to get to show five and the whole thing's just going to fall
apart.
So it's nice when it's over to know that it worked out.
But I'm always feeling like,
like I'm not having a ton of fun while I'm doing it,
but uh,
but,
but I am,
it's like working on some big account.
If you're an account executive and you're so happy when it's over and you go and
you toast the,
the team you worked with and all that at the end and very satisfying,
but while you're in the midst of it,
there's a lot of stress and pressure and deadlines and all that.
But listen,
that's life,
right?
Nothing's like you always have that.
No,
it's a,
it makes me think of my experience with publishing where after each book I tell
myself,
you know,
the next book's going to be a short book.
I always say that the next book is going to be a really short book,
going to take it easy,
break it down,
fast
cranking off.
It'd be nice and bite sized and a,
then of course after I have some type of series of nervous breakdowns every year
and a half or three years,
someone asks me,
well or they imply,
you know,
I assume the books must get easier after you do the first book.
The second must be much easier than,
than the third must be just rote by that point.
And I say no because I take everything that I've learned that w that should and
could make it easier and then I just double what I want to do or triple what I
want to do based on that new efficiencies up doing just as much if not more.
Oh,
it sounds exactly the same.
Exactly.
Listen,
from a creative standpoint,
you shouldn't want to have it any other way.
Right?
If you're the rolling stones and you're Keith Richards in that,
in that studio on the hundredth thing,
you want to be working that hard because you want to,
I mean,
you know,
there's an old line that that when you reach the top,
the only way to go is down.
Right?
And so when we hear that,
we just did an episode that people say,
well,
that's the best episode you ever did.
We instantly think to ourselves,
well,
you don't want to do anything worse than that.
That becomes the new minimum standard.
Right?
And truthfully,
if you don't give them something as good as that next time,
they're going to say,
wow,
you know,
it's not as good as that other thing.
So,
so we always feel,
and I think you do too.
I think everybody does,
when they're doing creative work,
the next thing needs to be better than the last thing.
So you're continually saying,
oh,
sure,
I didn't go in.
I almost went insane the last time.
I'm going to go in saying the next time.
It's the only way to ensure that I'm,
I'm a,
I'm pushing the limits.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
The high water mark must be surpassed.
How does Michael Jackson do better than thriller?
Right.
Oh God.
I don't even want to think about that,
but that would be a,
yeah,
I can't even imagine the,
um,
one of the many things that comes up listening to hardcore history is military
history and certainly with wrath of the cons,
the explanation of different techniques and approaches,
like the false flights or the false fleeing I found endlessly fascinating.
And it sounds like that's,
that's something that has fascinated you in military history.
Are there any particular people or techniques or strategies that you've found
most interesting?
I know that's a very,
I'm thankful that you find it interesting because I think,
and again,
something for podcasters who are,
who are just starting out maybe to pay attention to is if you talk about what
you find interesting,
eventually you will acquire a listenership that likes that too.
And so a lot of times I'll,
I'll,
I'll wonder if I'm not getting too deeply military on some of this stuff.
But then I realized that the people who are listening,
if they're still listening,
like liked that military stuff from earlier episodes that that was my focus in
college was military history.
And so that's what I've always been interested in.
I don't do rainbows and Unicorns is what I always tell people and it's dark.
I'll tell you something on your show.
No one else even knows Tim.
We're working on artwork for the specific shows that we've done.
I've got an artist cool and it is so dark and our artwork is dark.
Anyway,
my,
and I showed my wife the other day,
I was so proud of it and I said,
how do you look at this,
look at this art and and she comes over all excited to see the art and I can
watch her face drop and she goes,
it's horrible.
I said,
do you mean it's bad?
She goes,
no,
it just so dark and terrible.
I go,
the listeners will love it.
Then I said,
it'll just be present.
Just what we're after.
It matches the subject matter perfectly.
So,
I mean,
but look at,
it's what I like and you just figure if you try to make a show based on what you
think other people will like eventually you will have a show that you don't
like.
And so you have to do what you like.
And that's why this Internet is so wonderful and all these billions of people
out there,
if you only suck up one 10th of 1% of the pie of Internet users that like your
weird stuff that you bring up,
that translates into a lot of people.
I always tell folks,
I'm like a street performer really Tim.
I mean that's what I do.
I'm like that guy,
the mime on the street corner or the guy who plays the violin and he opens up
his violin case and you throw pennies on the street corner.
The guy who plays the violin,
I just work a really busy street corner and,
and that,
and that's what this is,
is that,
is that it?
You know,
if you're a niche market product,
the Internet is a place where that niche can,
can still translate into a ton of actual people.
So don't water it down.
You know,
there's a,
there's a phrase and we've all heard it,
but we don't think about what it means.
If you go on television,
on a TV network,
you are broad casting,
right?
You are reaching a broad segment of the audience.
The problem is,
is that to broadcast,
you have to water things down and widen them out to the lowest common
denominator.
We,
podcasters are narrow casters,
not broadcasters.
And you can't lose sight of the fact that that's,
that's not a bug.
It's a feature.
You know,
you want to be a narrow caster and you want to have this niche.
That's all yours is.
So if you're talking about invisible unicorns that you see on the weekend,
make that yours,
man,
your physical Unicorn on the weekend podcast and anyone else who does,
it's ripping you off,
right?
So I told you never to tell anyone about that.
I'm really
the Sasquatches him in my house podcast.
I mean that,
that's how it should be.
I don't think that when you're talking about a program that you should do it for
other people,
do it for yourself and military histories where I live.
Um,
I think the other thing that I have to keep emphasizing,
and I don't think you should be afraid of this too,
if I've learned anything from the podcasting,
it's don't be afraid to do something you're not qualified to do.
Yeah.
I tell the story all the time is that I didn't come up with the hardcore history
idea.
I have far too much respect for historians to a thought that I could have done
that as a history major with a degree.
I mean if the one,
the history majors know is how great historians are because we read them all the
time.
Right.
So I used to tell my stories that I've told my whole life and I was telling him
around the dinner table and my mother in law said to me,
you know,
cause I was already doing one podcast on current events and stuff and she said,
why don't you do a podcast on the stuff you're talking about here at dinner?
And I said,
oh,
I couldn't do that.
I said,
it's history and I'm not qualified to talk about history.
I don't have a doctorate.
I'm not a historian.
And she said,
I didn't realize you had to have a doctorate to tell stories.
And I thought about that for a minute.
I thought,
well listen,
most of the great historians from the non modern era didn't have doctorates
either.
They're just storytellers to it.
As long as I'm not purporting to be a historian,
and as long as I'm using their work.
And what I always will say is let's say there's a historical controversy,
I will tell you the controversy.
Then I will say,
well,
here's what historian a says about it and here's what historianB says about it.
And I've been surprised how much the listeners like to hear about what's called
historiography,
which is the process of how history gets written and made an interpreted.
They love hearing that.
And so you'll actually talk about the different theories.
And so I'm not making this stuff up.
I'm using the experts to tell you a story and the stories,
the part I'm qualified to tell you.
Oh No,
I that,
that's one of the,
one of the aspects of the show that I most appreciate is that you'll,
you'll point out the contradictions and you also talk about the different
schools of histories.
You'll have certain types of revisionist history.
You'll have different political leanings and how they interpret events,
say in the,
uh,
the Spanish American war,
founded,
you know,
the events and Cuba fascinating as well.
It's Philippines.
And,
uh,
it really helping people to realize that the biases at play in a lot of the
reporting in writing that we might otherwise assume to be objective.
Perfect example.
We talked about Rome,
ancient Rome and the republic period.
And you know,
the reason that people look at that period and think it looks a lot like our own
is because you can see some of the same political dynamics at work,
broadly speaking.
Right?
You know,
obviously there's a lot of time elapsed.
I often say to people,
imagine that there's a Fox News in ancient Rome and an MSNBC in ancient Rome.
So a left wing version of events and a right wing version of events.
Because what they always say is history journalism is the first draft of
history,
right?
So then imagine that only one of those narratives made it into your history
books,
right?
Roam as seen by Fox News or Roman politics as seen by MSNBC and how you can tell
the Roman story that way and it,
and if you do it and you contrast the two views,
it sounds even more modern.
So I do think that it actually sheds light on the events to point out the
different,
well,
I mean the Apaches,
uh,
a hundred years ago,
those are red murderers killing good Christian White settlers 30 years ago.
It's terrible,
horrible white people murdering blameless Indian.
I mean if you go through these periods where the entire focus and then the
public mood changes and we write history of different way,
those are fascinating in and of itself because it also teaches you that there
isn't necessarily truth here.
There's just the current perspective that's Invo.
Oh,
absolutely.
And I'm actually reading a book right now called dying every day,
which is a subtitle,
Seneca at the court of Nero,
and it's a very fascinating account of Seneca that tries to reconcile at some
level the opposing views and mythologies and facts surrounding this character.
Seneca,
who was a very famous stoic but at the same time was very,
very wealthy.
Some people called him opulent and just trying to point out the backgrounds of
the people who wrote these histories or who had these accounts were sending some
cases,
his political enemies.
It's really fascinating bus far because I,
I'm a,
I'm a huge fan of,
uh,
of Seneca and Marcus are released and a lot of these philosophers,
let me
stick stoics.
That's my favorite exact,
as you point out,
how much money,
the best kind of stoic to be the hedonist,
like premeditated spontaneity,
know
the media.
If I could shift gears a little bit,
ask just a handful of kind of rapid fire questions and a,
I'm having a lot of fun.
We could do this for a long time but I want to be respectful of your time but
I'd look to,
to throw off a couple of rapid fire questions and you can take as little or as
much time answering them as you'd like.
You have your hands in a lot these days.
You're doing quite a few different things.
What are the first say a hour or two of your day typically look like?
What are your morning rituals?
Oh,
I've had the same morning ritual for a long time.
It's the old talk radio show host or reporter ritual where I get up and I'm
really going to summit one of these days when books and newspapers go away.
I'm going to be really sad cause I,
I have to start with the newspaper like an idiot nowadays and I,
I bring it in,
I get the Cup of coffee out,
I start with the newspaper,
then I go online.
If I see any stories that piqued my interest,
I'll print them out.
I'll put them in a folder and then the next time it's time to do a current
events program.
I'll look in the folder and see,
you know,
we're on like 275 of those or something.
So it's getting awful hard to find new things to talk about that I don't feel
like we've already done.
But I spent the early morning while I'm waking up the First Cup of coffee or 10
catching up and reading mostly,
uh,
current events stuff.
What you do,
you wake up?
Oh goodness.
Well,
it's summer vacation now here at my house.
It's based on the children's schedule.
So when,
when it's school time,
it's like,
you know,
7:00 AM and we're up and at 'em,
uh,
now I can sleep a little bit later sometimes,
but I have a,
I have a sweet spot in my production ability where I'm at my best talking and
it's usually from about like nine to noon or one.
And so that's when I like to be in the studio.
I hit like two o'clock and all the coffee in the world's not keeping them,
you know,
and,
and so that,
that's why we're having this interview now,
Tim,
I remember the scheduling.
Yeah.
So I have this awful problem.
And when I'm dealing with east coast people,
it's really awful.
So I tried to get into the studio when,
when I've got a decent amount of energy and then by the time I'm out of there
and done,
then I'm spend the afternoon getting back into reading research cause there's a
lot of reading to do and I'm not,
I'm not the world's quickest reader.
And so,
um,
I also have a very tough time trying to figure out opportunity costs.
You know,
one of the things that,
that a lot of podcasters start to learn once their podcast becomes popular is
you're running a business now and that's not the part that most people,
yours truly included thought of when we got into podcasting.
Right?
You think about the product,
you don't think about the,
the edifice and structure that you have to maintain to keep the product going.
And I'm not gifted at that stuff.
And so where people will often say,
like on Twitter and stuff,
I'm wonder what you're doing in the three months since the last time you put a
history podcast and you can't,
you can't even begin to tell them all.
I mean,
just the website alone that I've been working on for a year is the time wasting
that goes on in my life and that you certainly,
I could do it better,
but like people will come to me and say,
Dan,
could you do this?
Or you do,
then you get these opportunities thrown your way because of the podcast and you
think to yourself,
I can't get a podcast out in three months.
How am I going to take advantage of any of these other opportunities that come
my way?
And so,
so I'm wrestling with how I do more because people have given me these chances
based on the fact that these listeners are so kind to listen to the show.
I don't know how to do them.
I don't know how to run this business.
So it's all I can do to get these shows that,
so when you talk about how you do these things,
and I wrestled with the business side of this every day to be honest.
Well I will,
uh,
we've,
we've chatted about this before,
but if I can help with any website stuff or whether it's wordpress related or
otherwise,
I'm happy to.
Tim,
I could abuse worse than you've ever been.
I've,
I've heard,
I've heard about your bookshelf full of tomes about medieval torture.
I know how you want it.
People who promised to help me with websites.
What is the newspaper that you read?
Is,
is there one newspaper that you consistently read?
Yes,
the stupid local one here
that just gets delivered to my front door easily.
And the funny thing is,
is everything I read in,
it's been printed two weeks ago on the Internet,
but I still just like some old person have to do an,
and I have to read it all the way to the end of the comics.
Like some,
like some person with OCD or something.
I just,
I can't help myself.
When I was in TV news before the Internet was doing news,
I used to get like five newspapers and you know,
and,
and I go through every one of them all day,
like an idiot.
I don't,
I don't do that anymore,
but,
but this is a silly local paper here in my local Berg.
I love it.
Uh,
and,
and when you're,
when you go online to potentially find a interesting current events or,
or angles to print out,
what are those sources?
Are there any particular sources that you repeatedly visit?
Um,
well,
a lot of Twitter has turned out to be really good way for listeners to share
with me.
Things that I think I'd be interested in.
And then they get a pretty good idea of the sort of things I like.
But no,
I go everywhere and I might start with Google news and then just,
you know,
I,
I check out all the British newspapers.
I check out the,
a major American newspapers,
there's some in Canada.
And then I liked going.
Wonderful thing about the internet,
the ability to kind of go local,
so if you're reading about stuff in between the Israelis and Palestinians,
for example,
like looking at the newspapers from the Middle East.
I like looking at various,
for example,
if you're looking for the Israeli side,
there are different Israeli newspapers with different perspectives and so,
so when I'm delving deep,
it's wonderful to have the internet that allows you to three dimensionalize in a
way that was not possible when I was getting five American newspapers in one day
to really,
I don't know if you end up being more intelligent on the subject,
but you could certainly give multiple viewpoints.
Does that make sense?
Oh definitely.
I remember my first real extended trip abroad in college.
This was after being in Japan as an exchange student,
but I was in China and I found the local English newspaper is contrasted with
the International Herald Tribune to be really mind opening because I'd never
been exposed to extremely different viewpoints on what I perceived to be exactly
the same phenomena or current events really was a,
was a,
was an eye opening experience for me.
Reviews what we always read when we're out of the country as those was all I
could get my hands on.
I know I've been there.
Uh,
what,
just to completely shift gears,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind?
Oh my goodness.
You know,
Tim,
I don't know.
I,
I you throwing some questions at me today and I'm this verbal person and I'm
usually pretty quick on my feet,
but I don't know how to answer that because my definition of success is perhaps
a little,
a little different.
You know,
I was arguing with somebody once about ambition and we were talking about
whether ambition was genetic or not,
and we were discussing happiness.
And I was trying to make the point that that successful being successful in life
means you're happy,
but that some people have to achieve certain things to be happy.
Right?
Right.
So,
so in other words,
I know people who can do nothing in their lives and be happy with that,
right?
So to me,
they're successful,
right?
But there's a lot of people who say,
well,
no,
no.
If I,
if I don't make a bunch of money or if I don't achieve something or if I don't
create something or,
or if I don't,
if you don't reach these particular goals,
then I'm not happy.
So in other words,
success for them requires in order to be happy,
requires that they do these other things to find happiness.
So to me,
being successful is being happy.
And so there's lots of people out there that I think have managed to be
successful.
Who,
who most of us have probably never heard of.
I tell you what,
there's a part of me that's even jealous of the people that can manage to be
happy without having to do a bunch of things to get there.
You know?
And I,
yeah,
I think,
I mean,
people look and say,
isn't it great what's going on with your podcast?
And I said yes because it makes me happy,
not because of any other amorphous or even concrete goals making this much money
or getting this much notoriety or whatever,
you know,
going on Tim Ferriss show and having him say all these nice things about me is
wonderful,
but the show itself makes me happy and,
and that's,
that's where the success comes in.
Now,
if we didn't make enough money to live,
I wouldn't do the show,
so I wouldn't be happy,
you know?
So I mean,
it all kind of boils down to the same thing.
We need different things to be happy,
but happy and successful are the same thing to me.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
no,
that makes sense.
The roundabout way of answering your question.
No,
no,
no.
That's a good answer.
They did the whole goal of the question,
sorry about very clever of you know,
the what,
what would be failure to you then it would it be being unhappy or is it
something,
is it something else entirely?
And that that could even be as it relates to the podcast if we wanted to,
to try to constrain it a bit to make it easier to answer it.
I'll tell you,
here's,
here's the worst part about having a podcast that people think are successful is
if you've never made it successful,
then you haven't screwed anything up.
You took a chance and you failed and that's part of life and it's part of
learning and it's part of success actually.
But if you manage to create something that's successful and then you screw it up
and blow it,
that that to me seems much more of a tragedy at a personal failure.
Then the never having gotten one off the ground at all.
So I think I was rather devil may care when we started these podcasts.
Now,
all I'm thinking about is if I don't do this blueprints of Armageddon part four
and have it be really good,
then then I've screwed up the golden goose.
Right.
So,
so failure to me is really,
you know,
like Keith Richards would have said in that rolling stones a studio,
you're only as good as the last thing you put out.
So failure is not putting out a piece of good work at this point in my mind.
Yeah,
no,
I definitely get it.
I mean,
I think especially with the Sophomore Act,
for me at least with the second book,
brought a lot of stress with it and it really,
really under the gun with the second book.
It's a perfect example,
very similar feeling.
Uh,
if you could change one thing about yourself,
what would it be?
I'd be more productive.
I think that's pretty easy.
I got out of the booth today in the studio and I didn't have anything useful.
I've been working on the same part for like three days now.
And you're just ready to smack walls.
I mean to sit there and feed so unproductive,
even though,
you know,
and I learned this,
I learned this writing as well,
where,
you know,
I remember writing something and setting myself a weekly total that I wanted to
hit,
right?
So every day I wanted to write this many hundred words and I would feel
productive and then you will get to the end of the week and you need to edit
what you wrote and you get rid of the 5,000 words or something and you just,
you,
you think to yourself,
oh my God,
what did I waste all that time for?
And I think that that's how creative endeavors often are.
So,
so like,
you know,
you asked me how these programs go.
There are days when I'll go in there and not like anything I do.
And they just feel like such a waste.
I could have used that time so much more constructively.
Had I only known it was going to be a wasted day at the microphone.
Right.
So yeah,
productivity.
I'd love to be more productive.
I'd love to be able to multitask.
I can't multitask either.
Don't you think,
just to,
to touch on what you just said,
don't you think though sometimes
that that day of seemingly wasted recording is necessary to just state get to
that one paragraph that is the one that everyone quotes you are absolutely 1000%
right and that is what it,
yes.
You're,
you're fumbling your way to glory.
That's my,
that's my,
my emo glory.
He should be the name of my next book,
text book.
I think we have a t shirt.
At least you're,
you couldn't be more right about that.
And I keep trying to console myself saying that it wasn't actually a wasted
created day even though 500 people on Twitter said,
where the hell is the next show,
Carl?
And get off the beach where you're my tie and I,
you know what?
I loved him.
I love that there are people out there who literally think I wait until the last
second and then I walk in and four hours later we have a show and I was just
making you wait.
I love those.
Those people think I'm Frank Sinatra.
I love those people.
Right.
And you know what,
and I'm going to start to cultivate that image that I really don't do anything
until the last second and then,
yeah.
Okay.
I'll give you a show.
Maybe tonight after dinner I'll crank one out for you.
Talk about making yourself in the immortal legend,
right?
I,
I just do those shows in real time to absolutely.
Yeah.
At one take Carlin
midnight and keep the band up late.
And then I just,
you know,
we're out there with an album.
So speaking of my ties,
you walk into a bar,
what do you order from bartender?
Something's straight.
You know,
I come from a family on both sides of,
of old fashioned men and that's the seamless way to describe him.
I don't smoke cigarettes like they did,
but it's hard to totally get away from your roots.
And they were hard drinking.
See,
they were so much tougher than I am too.
I don't have the toughness,
but I can drink like they drank.
And so,
so if I'm going to sit there,
if I'm going to go to a bar and drink,
I'm going to drink a straight whiskey or a straight rum or a straight vodka or
something like that.
I don't fool around.
Right,
right.
Skip the fourplex.
Right.
Come on.
It's a production done.
Right.
So I'm,
so I'm going with the Sinatra theme that you said.
So we talked about snotor.
Are we talking about drinking?
What's the first face that comes to mind when you think punchable punchable Oh,
you know,
I get,
so I have seen,
and this is where like if you get to my old shows on politics and current
events,
I sound so much angrier.
I think when I got into politics as a teenager,
I got in it from,
uh,
from,
and I think a lot of teenagers when they get to politics or early college
students,
it's out of anger.
You start to see the world as it's been created by the generations before you,
and you just feel like it's so screwed up.
And how can they deal with all the injustice in the world,
you know?
And so that's how I got into political talk radio for example.
It's just,
I was so mad at things that I saw that were just wrong in my opinion.
As I've gotten older,
I think I've been able to see more perspectives and,
and maybe be able to walk a mile in the other guy's moccasins a little bit
better.
But so when you say you know,
people that you would just want to punch and maybe it's a holdover wanting to
punch them from years and years ago,
but the people that drive me crazy,
I'm going to answer this question a certain way.
We did,
we did downgrade.
It's a slap also.
I'm not recrafting I just want to tell you that there,
there was a wonderful series called hell and the Pacific and it's uh,
it's on the,
the Second World War in the Pacific theater and I think it was made by a British
company.
And I remember being shocked because it had footage that we don't,
where we didn't show much in the United States of really horrifying Pacific
battles.
And they interview a US veteran who didn't die that long ago.
His name is Eugene Sledge and his nickname when he was in the Marines was
sledgehammer and he is,
he went on after he got out of the service to teach a school,
a college in I think it was Georgia and he's the most soft spoken,
wonderful,
sweet southern gentleman you've ever met.
And the whole hell in the Pacific series starts with him saying that no one
who's even yards behind the front line in war knows what it's really like and
nobody who does,
who hasn't been up there should be able to send young people off to war if you
haven't been.
And he means right on the front lines,
you have no place doing that.
The people that drive me crazy are the people in American politics who are,
I mean who,
who see war is the answer to everything and I don't even mean war.
I mean some of these,
John Bolton's,
the guy I always use,
he's the former you a American ambassador to the UN.
Just another one of these guys.
The himself avoided military service but sees sending other people to go do that
as his answer to every problem.
And I guess that just drives me nuts because as a guy who talks about military
history all the time and here's these accounts of veterans and realizes how
often their lives are forever altered even when they come home and seemingly one
piece,
you just want that to be such a really well thought out decision when you decide
to have people suck up that that lifetime of damage for some cause.
Just like Eugene sledge was saying,
you know,
anyone who's going to send someone off,
you've got to have a really good reason.
And I feel we've got a lot of people in the public sphere that didn't do this
themselves,
but for any reason are willing to go sell it to their people and they just make
me angry.
Like I'm 16 years old and into punk rock,
which I'm still into and mad and,
and you do,
you get Irish and just,
I'm ready to become a stereotypical,
you know,
punch somebody in the mouth.
And it's really,
it's really a,
a piece of me that's mostly dead now that comes back and haunts me at moments
just at the wrong time.
It's always at the wrong time.
So speaking of,
of Punk Rock,
what are the most frequently played bands or songs on your,
whether it's
a computer,
iPhone or otherwise?
Oh God.
I go through,
I go through phases where I just kill something,
you know,
and I,
I'll just,
I'll get back into the dead Kennedys and then it's like two weeks of just
nothing but that until I can't listen anymore.
And then I'll move to,
I've never quite discovered the variety is the spice of life thing.
I have to like eat all Sushi for like two weeks until I can't have anymore.
You know,
and I don't like Sushi,
but I just,
it was an example and that's how I am with music.
I mean,
I would buy it back in the days of record albums,
the new record album,
and play it 200 times and then never want to hear it again or you know.
So I like all the old stuff too.
When you go back to like Lou reed or the seeds or to me,
even Jerry Lee Lewis is punk rock.
To me that's an attitude.
Not a,
not a sound.
So I just like all those,
to me music is about so much more than the listening experience that just a
basic philosophy and music.
Is it about the technical expertise of the musician or the busyness of the
melody?
Or is it about tribal drums that get your blood going and you know,
and I'm much more of the tribal drum person than I am about,
I worked with a lot of audio people and for them they want to hear technical
expertise and wonderfully crafted and I want to hear something from the soul,
you know?
Oh for sure.
I'm just getting into hand drums.
So I'm,
I'm all about the drums.
Very,
it's very emotional and ancient story.
I love it.
So last question,
potentially,
if you could give one or two pieces of advice to your 20 year old self,
what would it be?
Oh,
I think about this all the time.
I remember coming out of the television station where I was a TV reporter and I
was working the night shift and I had just worked on some stories all day and
was just thoroughly unsatisfied with them by the time they hit a hair.
And I remember walking out of the station at like midnight and it was up on the
top of this mountain,
beautiful place.
Uh,
and,
and I,
and I remember looking out and just say,
oh my God,
when am I going to like this?
You know,
when,
when am I gonna what am I going to really be,
be happy with the work that I'm churning out.
So I look back on that all the time when I think of where I am now and just
think if I could go back and just tell myself,
don't stress about it.
It's all gonna work out in the end.
What did any of us like to know that?
Just just tell me it's all going to be okay and I can get by in my twenties
twenties were really,
really hard for me.
I thought,
and if you could have just said stop worrying,
it's all going to be okay.
Although I'm assuming it's all going to be okay,
Tim.
I still don't that,
but I,
but I think I would have saved a ton of emotional stress and worry.
I'm a,
I'm a natural born worrier and I think it would have been nice,
although if you'd have told me that I might relaxed so much that that reality
might never have occurred.
So you know,
that's why you can't go back in the time machine and step on the butterfly.
You'll screw up everything.
So I won't go back and tell myself that Tam,
because I'll screw up my future.
That's right.
But if there's an aircraft carrier headed back to Pearl Harbor,
you'll at least sit down and watch the,
I don't know how I,
I don't know how I can apply that.
Come up with a good concept that I'm here.
So then this,
this has been a lot of fun.
I want people to listen to more of your stuff.
What episodes would you like people to listen to?
What's the starter kit if you want to get people hooked?
I have my own thoughts but,
but what episodes of hardcore history would you recommend people start with?
Well,
I wouldn't start with the really old ones because I don't think they are
representative of what we've evolved into.
It's not that I don't like them,
it just,
I think that people who liked the really old episodes sometimes miss the way
they sounded and the people that like the current ones don't as much like the
old ones.
So I'd still,
I'd start with something new just because if you like that you might get more of
it.
If you listen to the old stuff,
you're not getting any more of that.
I think I would simply pick it based on the subject matters.
So pick,
we have a certain number of shows.
We usually leave the new shows up for a year or two before we,
or three before we were moved them to the paid archives.
So we should have a decent mix of things.
We do something called blitz additions sometimes,
which we're supposed to be shorter but they aren't shorter.
Uh,
cause I'm too long winded.
But,
but they just,
they turned out to be about slightly different focuses.
So instead of focusing on an event,
one of the blitz additions that we did focused on,
you know,
where people in the old days tougher than we are.
I think the question we asked is could you beat your grandparents in a war?
And then we did another one on,
I think we called it intoxicated priority.
Oh No.
History under the influence we called it and it was the hidden effect of
intoxicating substances may be on the past.
And so those are the wave blitz additions.
More look at weird subjects like that.
And then the other episodes look at historical events.
So I would say pick one that sounds like it's an interesting piece of subject
matter and then keep your fingers crossed that we,
that we pulled off that episode halfway decently and that's how I would
do.
And that's the,
that's the gateway drug into hardcore history.
I would say for those interested in my personal recommendations,
I have yet to dislike any of the episodes.
I think wrath of the cons is,
is outstanding.
If you're interested in in warfare and tactics and uh,
the lore of,
uh,
not Gingiss Khan,
but Genghis Khan,
I guess it turns out then I,
I think that's a fantastic series of the prophets of doom.
I got to say,
I know you,
I know,
I know you weren't happy with it for whatever reason.
Uh,
I know you have your reasons,
but
no,
I'll tell you why.
Because I was saving that story.
That is one of the great twisted history stories of all time and I remember
thinking to myself,
okay,
you are halfway to a good show before you say your first words with this story.
And so I had really high hopes for how great cause it's just the story itself is
so wonderful.
You don't need Dan Carlin,
you're too much performance anxiety.
I really enjoyed that episode.
You teased the hell out of it.
In the beginning I got to say was I was getting antsy for for a little bit in
the very beginning,
but it's giving you context though.
You have to understand that the reformation for that thing.
Oh No,
I love the reformation,
but uh,
the,
the lead is fantastic.
I'm not going to give away too much of the story.
I would tell you,
listen,
don't listen to that when there's too much setup.
Uh,
so I'm going to let people explore where can people best find you on the
interwebs?
Where would you like people to find you online?
Listen,
you can,
uh,
you can get the free shows from our website@dancarlin.com.
There were obviously on iTunes as well.
You can get the old shows off our website.
Uh,
I think they were a little cheaper off our website,
but you can get them on iTunes as well.
Type my name into the search engine somewhere,
the right thing you should pop up.
Uh,
listen,
I'm just happy you're sharing my stuff with your listeners.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Oh,
my pleasure.
This,
I just having attempted to do some form of a podcast myself now for a little bit
and having listened to a lot of podcasts,
the amount of effort that you've put into each of these episodes is I think
magnitudes of order better than most audio books.
And that's saying,
well,
I've listened to hundreds,
Oh man,
think about this.
This is the real key.
The real key is that we live in an era where we can do this stuff because I can
tell you right now,
you look at podcasting and there's about 20 or 30 really creative podcasts out
there that you would never be allowed to do in a million years in the movie of
20 years ago.
And yet when you listen to them,
you just think is just brilliant,
right?
And so if we're lucky enough to be in that category where you go,
oh gosh,
this is something that would never be in the mainstream media,
and I'm so glad I found it,
then we're really fortunate.
I,
to me,
that's as somebody who came from that media and by the time I left it,
it was so the opposite of creative.
The fact that we could,
we've got this blank canvas where we can be creative again.
What a great time to live,
right?
Oh,
it's amazing.
It's amazing.
I mean,
you've got,
you know,
everything from,
of course,
what you might expect,
like the,
this American life,
uh,
to say welcome to Nightvale,
which is like one of the weirdest things imaginable,
which is a,
as it stands,
I mean,
always in the top 10 on iTunes.
It's a hell of an open playing field.
And like you said,
narrow casting,
it's,
uh,
it's just ripe for the picking.
People can be as weird as they want to be in.
They'll find their audience if they're passionate enough about it.
Well,
listen,
if you're gifted,
I always think about it this way.
Can you imagine someone has gifted as Eddie Murphy when he first showed up on
the comedy scene,
or Richard Pryor when he first showed up at the comedy scene.
If they simply,
you know,
the,
the Mike can be bad,
the audio can be bad.
You might not get shows out very frequently,
but if Eddie Murphy were simply doing a podcast today when he first started out,
that would be his ticket to fame and fortune without ever needing to make it on
a Saturday night live first or anything like that.
I mean,
this is,
this is direct media to the public.
We've never had it like this and I'm not even sure it's going to last.
This is,
this may be a wonderful little golden opportunity
in human communication.
Take advantage.
Now if you've ever thought of having a podcast,
it's a good time to get in.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Well then this has been a blast.
I really appreciate your time.
I'm going to continue to listen again to the entire series of wrath of the gods,
which I use for my morning walks.
Everybody,
everybody as twisted as me.
I know,
I know you're going to start getting weird letters from Mason,
but I recommend everybody check it out.
And if you've ever thought of starting a podcast,
well maybe now's the time to do it and I'll be writing a lot more about that.
So then I appreciate it.
I will,
uh,
I will talk to you soon and a really good hanging out.
Thank you very much for having me on,
man.
It looks continuous success.
You're doing great.
Thanks man.
I'm,
uh,
I'm just,
I'm stolen the training wheels,
but I'm learning as I go,
so thanks.
Thanks again.
I'll talk to you soon.
Anytime.
All right.
You want more of the Tim Ferriss show?
You can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes or go to for our blog.com [inaudible]
dot com where you'll find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park,
the books plus much,
much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com slash t Ferris.
That's top RRIF SAS or on Facebook at facebook.com/tim Ferris.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.